sì cavolo finalmente guardiamo il primo
episodio di tutti in campo con lotti era
una vita che aspettavo questo momento
non solo è uno dei miei cartoni animati
preferiti nonostante l'abbia guardato
con la programmazione della mediaset
degli anni 90 e quindi non ci abbia
capito un cavolo però è il cartone
animato che mi ha fatto scoprire il golf
e me lo ha fatto piacere non sono ancora
arrivati a livelli del giocarlo perché
non sono un ricco annoiato e solo super
eccitato di vedere il primo episodio con
voi quindi questo è il primo episodio di
tutti in campo con lotti ma qualcuno se
lo ricorda perché quando parlo con i
miei amici tipo solo io l'ho visto sto
cartone animato no ma sono sicuro che
qualcun altro abbia visto vero vero
l'episodio inizia con il nostro
protagonista che dorme beatamente
durante la lezione latte non si viene a
scuola per dormire ma per studiare ma
questo è un professorone di stirpe
questo dispensa consigli meglio di
biscotti della fortuna
l'arte non si viene a scuola per dormire
ma per studiare l'acqua è bagnata
questo è grigio questo mi inquieta
grazie prof
grazie lotti decide di cambiare posto
con il suo ultimo compagno di banco per
poter dormire è il professore non dice
nulla
sì era proprio così che funziona va a
scuola anche noi potevamo dormire
indisturbati sul banco con il collo
spezzato e come se non bastasse fa anche
il culo ai suoi compagni di classe
ma dov'è dalla terza riga di pagina 176
si e poi diamogli sulla fiducia un oscar
alla carriera già che ci siamo dopo
scuola lotti in contrattacchi la sua
compagna che gli chiede cosa vorrà fare
dopo aver finito le medie a quale delle
scuole superiori anche insieme di scrivo
io non mi iscriverò le superiori ma devo
trovare un lavoro che mi faccia
guadagnare un sacco di soldi ha quindi
non andare a scuola va a fare comunque
tanti soldi
comunque quello che ho in mente è
diventare un grande uomo d'affari ma lui
voleva soltanto diventare un uomo
d'affari ma ci riuscirà sicuramente
senza andare a scuola era non iscriverà
le superiori anche io ho saltato
l'università e sono diventato ingegnere
aerospaziale grazie a un tutorial su
youtube dai andando non è da quella
parte casa tua per arrotondare ho
accettato anche un lavoretto in una
stazione di servizio ma cazzo da noi per
riuscire a dare un curriculum di
scriverci sopra tutti gratis altrimenti
non unico non è anche è un ragazzino
delle medie a non uno ma due lavori e
per ora mi arrangio a vendere bibite al
dolphin arrotondare ho accettato anche
un lavoretto in una stazione di servizio
la madre invece fa la cuoco in un
ristorante
io invece voglio subito merluzzo bollito
corrida e verdura o a quanto pare io ho
sempre sbagliato ad ordinare non serve
aspettare il cameriere basta urlare
direttamente al cuoco quello che vuoi in
modo fastidioso da un'altra parte nella
stanza e cosa sta facendo mio figlio non
è con la rinata lavora alla stazione di
servizio aqua di fronte a un dio o da
quale calcio di pianeta sei uscito tu
non perché sia nero ma monociglio naso
incredibilmente largo che sembra si sia
incastrato dentro un pesce gli occhi
distanti almeno 20 centimetri incrociati
sei al cento per cento sicuro di non
avere una qualche forma rarissima di
malattia mortale
non perché chiaramente il disegnatore ti
odia quindi di un controllino che lo
farei alla stazione di servizio in cui
lavora lotti il proprietario è un
appassionato di golf a natale che a te è
davvero un ragazzo in gamba quel lotto
grazie per averlo detto quando in giro
non c'era più nessuno un vecchio pazzo
dopo il lavoro lotti deve anche tenere a
bada i suoi tre fratellini disordinati
non borbottare che ho detto di pulire
questa stanza e david bisogni capito
e anche tu pendi metti subito via quel
libro sono stato adriano ragazzo ma
ancora così tante energie questo renzi
nella macchina mamma posso darti una
mano
posso darti una mano posso darti una
mano lotti io ti voglio bene ma figlio
mia devi darti una cazzo di calmata mi
fai sentire una merda per tutti quei
giorni che non ho aiutato i miei
genitori in casa non posso sprecare
tutto il tempo nello studio mamma ma non
volevo dire questo scusa eh sì
soprattutto se punisci come uno di quei
pupazzoni gonfiabili allo stadio
praticamente tiene ferma la mano e muove
il bacino magari funziona come
l'astronave di futurama cioè il rimane
fermo ed è tutto un universo che si
sposta intorno a lui mi è venuta una
fantastica idea per un crossover e siamo
arrivati a metà puntata e io inizio a
chiedermi come entrerà nel mondo del
golf
la risposta arriva il giorno dopo quando
si ritrova ovviamente a vendere polpette
di riso i golfisti e tre di loro vi
giuro su dio completamente a caso lo
sfidano lei visto che basti che spesso
da queste parti sicuramente qualche
volta avrei provato a giocare a golf
no non l'ho mai fatto riesce a fare un
bel tiro sono disposta a pagare due
volte la roba che abbiamo preso giusto
per sicurezza e gli un ghetto qui la
definizione di random voi dateci
un'occhiata che non si sa mai ma lotti
da grande campione li mette tutti a
tacere
no
il ragazzino se ti puoi levate dai
[ __ ] che dobbiamo giocare grazie
però gli danno una seconda possibilità
riproponendo la sfida il giorno dopo che
domani ci mostrerà i quello che sai fare
ripeto definizione di random solo a me
tutto questo sembra stupido sembra molto
tirata per i capelli come scusa per
entrare nel mondo del golf
soprattutto per un ragazzino che alla
capacità di studiare dormendo fare due
lavori contemporaneamente aiutare la
madre e gestire tre fratellini più
piccoli
e come se un futuro avvocato ad un certo
punto decidesse di diventare fashion
blogger di stupido per prepararsi alla
sfida si allena con la mini mura del suo
capo e poi con una mazza da baseball per
tutta la notte signora prima mortivi o
fermi suo figlio che a 30 anni se lo
ritrova molto con un infarto fulminante
arriva però il momento della sfida che
consiste nel superare i 150 metri di
lancio sono 150 metri che cosa sono 150
metri all'inizio ha difficoltà ma poi
ovviamente riesce ad arrivare
addirittura a 180 metri cominciato la
pallina di almeno 180 metri è vera ma
non manca qualcosa quel momento che c'è
in tutti i cartoni sportivi orientali
quel momento in cui qualsiasi tipo di
palla venga usata in campo si trasforma
in una mozzarella di bufala sparata a
300 chilometri orari nel vuoto cosmico
e credibile un tiro da campione
e è un vero campione e il tutto finisce
con una frase da incorniciare anche la
sua mazza signore grazie ancora
quindi questa era la prima puntata di
tutti in campo collotti beh è
sicuramente meno peggio di quel che mi
aspettassi però devo dire che è molto
debole per i miei gusti per quanto
riguarda l'approccio al golfo del
protagonista sarebbe potuto essere
scritto in mille altri modi diversi
hanno scelto questo non importa
la cosa bella è stata che questa puntata
mi ha intrattenuto molto di più di
quella delle fatture tinge di quella di
mila e shiro peccato però che in questo
episodio non ci sia la frase per
eccellenza di tutto il grafo gallotti
quando uno inizia a giocare a golf
seriamente usa una parola per mantenere
la concentrazione durante il tiro e
questa parola continua a citarla ancora
adesso e me la porto dietro da talmente
tanti anni che me ne vergogno ma ciò
solo fusilli posso giocare lo stesso
golf
buongiorno e benvenuti al primo tutorial
su youtube come diventare ingegneri
aerospaziali senza studiare prima di
tutto prendete anni di appunti e libri e
lanciate le via secondo fatevi amico un
ingegnere aerospaziale e rubate di la
laurea